- You've heard all about it.
Apple's Vision Pro.
It's the company's biggest
bet yet on a future
beyond the iPhone.
Let's do this.
(upbeat music)
Yes, I got my hands on it and
didn't take it off my face
for 24 hours.
Oh, amazing.
Or at least the better part of 24 hours.
Ugh, that feels really nice.
Ever since Apple announced
this headset, I've wondered
how is it going to fit in our lives?
We've already got screens everywhere.
What does this $3,500
face computer do better?
Since I couldn't test it
for long stretches in my real house.
Can you see my eyes?
- No.
(child mutters)
- I headed to the Pocono Mountains
and rented this ski cabin
because what are these really,
if not super high tech ski goggles?
No one's gonna know.
So it's noon, which is
the start of this journey.
What could go wrong?
As soon as you put on the headset,
you see the real world.
Right here is a grid of apps.
The home screen.
You just look at what you wanna select,
then you use your hands to select it.
Right now I'm looking at
settings, now App Store, Notes,
photos, Safari,
and to select one I just pinch.
It's really intuitive.
And to scroll, you just pinch and drag.
The coolest thing is how you
can place apps all around you.
Apple calls this spatial computing.
So I can start writing over here
in a document in front of me.
I've got email over here on the left
and I've got music over here on the right.
I was all set up to do some real work,
except one big problem.
This is typing.
Yeah, it's a struggle for anything
longer than a quick message.
Thankfully, I have never been
so happy to see a keyboard.
The real game changer
for getting work done.
Adding in a Mac.
We are connected.
Yes, you get a giant
desktop for your Mac apps
and you can run Vision Pro
apps right next to them.
And you too can have this
for the low, low price of.
But really, I continued
to work in the headset
for the next few hours and got a lot done.
Next, I had to prepare my persona.
Remove Apple Vision Pro to begin
capture, fix my hair, lips.
Can I get a light?
- [Computer] Keep your
arms and shoulders relaxed.
- See, when you video call in the headset,
it can't capture your entire face.
Most of the Vision Pro's
cameras are pointed outward.
So Apple scans your face to
create a 3D stand-in for you.
- [Computer] Smile with your mouth closed.
Capture complete.
- It says creating persona.
What is going on with my cheeks?
- And when I FaceTime
people looking like this,
it was universally agreed upon.
- I think you look awful.
- It's like Botox from hell.
- They did you so dirty, dog.
- What?
And yes, FaceTiming with
other people in Vision Pro is
as crazy as you'd think.
Oh my goodness.
Sure there's a lot of
remarkable tech here,
but can you really take
me seriously right now?
Apple says the persona feature is in beta.
That persona scan is also used
to show your eyes on the front display
so people know you're looking at them.
But it can be hard to see.
I'm looking right at you.
Now, it would be around this point
where most people would take
a break from this thing.
I think it was the
combination of FaceTiming
and screen recording.
But the top of this is very warm.
I think it's time to switch
into the the dual loop band
and feels pretty good.
I ended up being happy that
Apple didn't strap this
thing's battery to my head.
I got used to the hanging pack,
especially when I put it in this.
It's as cool as a Blackberry holster.
I had to charge the battery
every two to three hours.
So most of the time I just
stayed plugged into the wall,
but not for my next activity.
And here is our recipe, balsamic
mushroom and sausage pasta.
Crouton is a recipe
app for the Vision Pro.
So I put the window on one side
of the kitchen and got cooking.
It is not recommended to
prepare food while wearing
the Apple Vision Pro.
Okay, sure. Don't worry.
My producers were standing
by to make sure I was safe.
Prepping food was really natural,
especially I could cut
onions all day in this.
My eyes do not burn.
This is amazing, but
the absolute best thing.
So I see the timer here
and now I can move it over the pasta.
And now I have a second
timer for six minutes
that I'm putting over the mushrooms.
This is just the coolest.
Was it perfect?
No.
You're still looking at life on a screen.
In low light,
I couldn't read things with smaller print
because of pixelation.
Is there even Pepper coming
out? I cannot see it.
And some stuff just didn't
look like the right color,
but the display quality is far
better than the other leading
though far more affordable headset.
The $500 Meta Quest 3.
This is pretty much ready.
That's very good.
(pensive music)
What should I watch?
Let's start with some Apple TV.
You can create a giant
personal home theater
in the Vision Pro.
Because of rights,
I couldn't screen record the 2D
or 3D movies and shows that I watched.
And even then seeing it in this video
wouldn't do it justice.
There's Apple TV Plus, Disney
Plus and Paramount Plus,
but no Netflix or YouTube apps.
You have to watch those
through the browser.
And the cinematic 3D virtual reality
videos Apple's offering.
This is the kind of stuff
that makes me nauseous.
I do like one of the
virtual reality features.
Turn the digital crown
on the top of the headset
and I am now
in 180 degree view of Yosemite.
If you're like me and glasses on, you have
to get prescription inserts
to use The Vision Pro.
I just click in like that.
Wow. Crazy browser.
Okay, I didn't sleep
with it. I'm not insane.
Morning everyone.
(coffee dripping)
That sounds delicious.
Siri, what's the weather gonna be today?
- [Siri] 51 and a chance of Rain.
- Perfect skiing conditions.
Let me be clear. No one
should ski with these on.
Apple's very explicit when
you first set up the headset
to only use it in safe areas.
But I headed to Camelback anyway
and worked with the mountain
to make sure the entire bunny
hill was closed off from others.
Hi. And I only wore them
briefly to record some video.
Siri record spatial video. Nope,
you gotta press the button.
Poles on. Gloves on.
Here we go.
The Vision Pro's ability to record
and then watch Spatial or 3D images
and videos is pretty great.
You can record spatial
video with an iPhone 15 Pro,
but hands-free recording
is one of the best uses
of connected eyewear like Meta's Ray Bans.
So what's it like wearing these for a day?
Painful, but also insightful.
The Vision Pro has every characteristic
of a first generation product.
It's heavy, it's battery life sucks.
There aren't that many great apps yet.
And sometimes it's bugged. No.
And oof. Personas.
But when you imagine a device
without those constraints,
you see where it could be better than
holding a phone to your face.
Vision Pro is a cooking computer.
For right now,
it gives you a pretty great
way to work and watch movies.
Is that worth $3,500?
That's between you and your bank account.
But in those 24 hours,
I could see Apple's future vision here.
A pixelated yes, and a little
distorted glimpse of it.
That is, where are you?
(laughing)